Austin is with us Austin is in Tennessee
hi Austin welcomes the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]
great how can we help you tell my wife
they stole the house about two weeks ago
and they're walking away with around
6,000 and so we got the money we paid to
call her off and we have a five acre
tract of land we're trying to figure out
to pay it off or hold off on that or
possibly do what are you gonna do with
it don't build on them at some point now
it might be a year from now where are
you living
we just started written after we sold
the home okay well if you what's the
land what's the payoff on the land
it's a 32,000 okay and how much of the
60 have you got left after paying off
the car that's 45 okay
all right do you have an emergency fund
yes we do okay good
you have any other debts no okay
Wow feels pretty good doesn't it it does
yeah I paid off today the bank's telling
us the bank's telling us don't pay it
off and I'm thinking pay it off dude
yeah well banks are in the business of
loaning money it's so we don't you
really use them for a financial advice
they would keep you in debt forever my
brother so yeah I'd pay it off today and
here's what we would do then take the
balance that little bit of money that's
left and set that aside and start adding
to it for additional money to use for
the building when you get ready to build
you can take the paid off land to the
bank and they will take they will loan a
construction loan against that property
and against the house that's being built
okay so it kind of X the paid off land
kind of X almost is your down payment
for your construction loan and then so
let's say you spent I don't know just
make up a number $200,000 to build a
house okay in addition to the land and
so they would loan you that
two hundred thousand dollars and it
would come out as the house is being
built to pay the Builder on the
construction loan the drawers are taken
against the actual progress of the
building and then when the house is
completed that loan would be converted
to a permanent mortgage a traditional
mortgage which you would have already
been pre-approved for on a 15-year fixed
in the house payment would be no more
than 1/4 of your take-home pay if you're
following our stuff but my point is
there's no downside to you know if you
break ground next spring a year from now
on that house that paid for property is
gonna allow you to do that now if you're
gonna buy another house and that five
acres just gonna sit over there I
wouldn't pay it off I'd sell it okay but
if you're gonna build on it
then you know it makes it's the same as
making a down payment on your next house
to pay it off you see what I'm doing
yeah yeah so let's go ahead and get
plans going to build on it pretty quick
here I don't mean I wouldn't be renting
a long time I'd get some plans drawn
pick out a builder Rachel you and listen
just went through building a house it's
quite an experience yeah it's fun
we actually enjoyed it some people hate
it and they get stressed and all that
but we personally we loved it it helps
that Winston is a real estate guy and a
project manager extraordinaire
yes that's and she's detailed well
that's what I make every every every
piece of the schedule every May we'd
still be building probably the Builder
would already have shot himself I just
appreciated Austin's like common sense
when you made the bank comment he said
you know the bank's telling me to keep
it but I think I just need to pay it off
I'm like yes that's it I mean like that
gut instinct that we have as consumers
it is still still real I mean yeah you
reason to that you know most people have
common sense but there's always somebody
trying to tell them not to use it
yes exactly